hey guys hey guys hey guys hey guys hey
guys I'm Ryan right I'm Dan Schneider
we're gonna check out today halo 5 a
hero falls
oh he be commercial it's like we watched
something about halo 5 before in the
past tonight now it's like okay so halo
5 here we you know Jesus had a halo you
know this had a halo he did it was
really noticeable everywhere he went it
was like a halo she's with him bet
everywhere that's what the pictures tell
me and I thought when I heard halo when
the first was announced the years ago I
was like sweet we're finally a video
game based off playing as Christ
I was wrong then worship some Master
Chief 2560 sponsored one one seven the
man most commonly known as the Master
Chief don't
in the line of duty how to respect to
those who may have market less once in
the event we are holding back the
complete account the Master Chief would
never have agreed to special treatment
to be elevated above anyone else but we
must acknowledge the locks we have all
our entire species suffered today and we
must fight together as he fought we must
end this
that's how I got taken out I was really
confused for a second then I remembered
that video games that Kenneth
occasionally like to give you this false
hope that they are adapting something
awesome and she cinema that was not the
game that was that the case took me a
while to just like cuz I was like even
the shot of the building is falling I
was like yes looks like it would be a
really good movie ok that's it that's a
great way to set up the atmosphere of
Halo honestly Dan I don't really play
that many video games and so people just
asked me to check out these trailers for
games and that's why you're here so
that's why I'm guys here you're inside
Stan right now I'm just trying to
decipher any form of plot because
remember we watch this two other
live-action trailers with oh my god I
can't remember his name the other
Spartan and Master Chief
like those two things well I saw another
trailer where you're essentially playing
as a team yeah that one we watched
now it's like Master Chief died did he
really probably not probably not most
likely not you know if he died we would
see it they wouldn't show it in the
trailer yeah exactly yeah if Master
Chief died it would not be like uses a
marketing good by the way
spoiler alert I don't gave the Master
Chief's kidnapped that's yeah I don't
buy that for one second no and I think
that kind of leads into the fact that he
kind of goes underground yeah he's like
Nick Fury
you know like running Shield underneath
I could dig it yeah I could dig it too
we saw some gameplay we've seen the last
amount of trailers I just want to play
the game now yeah that's all I mean
that's that's where I'm at I'm ready to
play I feel like they're really trying
to make this halo feel more personal you
know like Webb putting Master Chief's
life really like is he actually dead and
stuff so and like they're seeing the
shots of like the you know the cities
and like he was a fallen hero and
everything yeah
so I feel like there
trying to give you a much more personal
vibe the Halo games like other than that
it's like they just get it with the
gameplay they get you know like
additionally a little cooler each time
yeah but rare is it where they like
leader like this is so different and
better so I feel like they're trying to
amp it up with creating a more personal
story that's what um the the new
developer the guys that took over from
Halo 3 to Halo 4 3 4 3 that was what
they really wanted to do they wanted to
try to humanize Master Chief and so like
Halo 4 it was kind of there there was
some really weird moments with Cortana
there trying to make it more than just
like Master Chief kicks down door shoots
all aliens everybody goes home happy so
I'll be interesting to see what the
story does in that respect but so far
gameplay looks good I mean it looks like
it's gonna be a good game the effexor
were great it looks so real yeah so real
tip graphics so many pixels it looked
real what game trailers do that man like
don't [ __ ] do that they want you to
buy the game I know you'd want to buy
the game for some or buy the game but
anything gonna be like you know I just
wanna see a halo movie that's our one
quick little thing
I thought the find it hysterical that
that kid was playing with a Master Chief
action is your winner in that universe
military hero he was the action yeah
anyway guys anyway guys if you're if
you're new to the channel you can
subscribe and become a reject door I
can't come up with anything damn a
reject door I'm trying to come up with a
thing you know you wanna go I call my
guys the cyber nuts yeah yeah and Tyrone
calls his the Magna sites
what's wrong with rejects that's cuz you
say that and it doesn't sound like you
belong to anything but because we are
the rejects we're together we're hanging
out
more like one of the region well then
we're technically not rejects because we
rejects see the problem with if it is
wrong I can't I don't know what to call
the fan base you can check out dance
channel and become a cyber not I play
games it's cool cyber not it's like
space you become a rhinoceros
Damon O'Neil hey guys I'm a newcomer to
your channel but I absolutely love it
makes me laugh every single time I watch
you guys especially you Ryan never stop
the sexual jokes never let go I'm not
sure exactly how you guys go about
picking videos to watch exactly but I
think you should check out the trailer
hopefully you'll choose to reaction on
your channel love you guys keep up the
amazing work Damon O'Neil I'm glad we're
satisfying you today but listen dude I'm
less interested in you and more
interested in seeing who this woman is
in your photo cannot whoa do you lucky
[ __ ] I want to go legit dude
your hair's incredib you're like a dirty
blonde zach braff Cheverly yes good job
good good good on you I'm sure on the
channel I wish she would come on this
channel